back to Sunday night's Emmys is going to
have a good dose of Oscar winners in the
house and now we know just where they
will be sitting
[Music]
Reese Witherspoon Nicole Kidman Viola
Davis and Oprah all that assigned the
prime spot to watch the show the front
row I'm coming for your Reese Chrissy
Metz is sitting behind her TV dad Milo
Ventimiglia Walt sterling Kate Brown is
across the aisle but this is us stars
hit The Hollywood Reporter sag after a
party where Sterling dropped some intel
on when Milo's character Jack dies this
season the scene that gives you the most
information regarding Jack's demise but
something that we shot just this week Oh
so that there will be no leaks and no
spoilers anything go happen from the
brother man the tear-jerking shows dr. K
Gerald McRaney celebrated his win at the
creative arts Emmys his wife Delta Burke
is still bursting with pride I had never
had tears projectile out of my eyes like
that and I just went to pieces I was so
excited I won this for him for so long
and today on the talk Emmy host Stephen
Colbert revealed he's already shot a bit
for the show where he's naked I was a
buck naked like an hour and a half in
front of the camera another board knows
what Colbert is gonna do he's gonna go
full monty like literally and physically
anything the show airs live on CBS this
Sunday and of course ET will be on the
red carpet and of course backstage to
bring you everything